[Hillary] They are called super predators, no conscience,
no empathy.
[Hillary] Last time I actually drove a car myself was
1996.
[Hillary] Whew! okay.
[Hillary] I can't drive anymore.
[Hillary] I am running.
[Trump] Hello
[Hillary] Hello
[Trump] Are you running?
[Trump] We have a problem.
[Trump] Those people are trying to kill us.
[Trump] This is really scary.
[Trump] They make Saddam Hussein look like a choir
boy.
[Hillary] I call the basket of deplorables.
[Trump] They're calling them all sorts of great names.
[Hillary] They are called super predators.
[Trump] Excuse me, I'll use the word anchor babies.
[Trump] I will build the greatest wall.
[Hillary] Looking back, it would have been better for
me to use two separate phones.
[Trump] I will make that wall im-penetrable, okay?
[Trump] impenetrable.
[Trump] And, actually it'll even look great.
[Trump] I already know what it should look like.
[Hillary] We don't wanna build walls we wanna build
bridges.
[Trump] I think she's crazy, I think she's crazy.
[Trump] We have no idea who these people are.
[Trump] Bing!
[Hillary] Well that hurts my feelings.
[Trump] She just fainted.
[Trump] I assume that was pneumonia also.
[Trump] Is that okay?
[Trump] I don't know what it is, maybe she's lazy.
[Trump] I will take care of women, I respect women,
I will grab 'em by the pu-
[Trump] Something's going on and it's not good.
[Trump] I have a feeling it may be Obama's fault.
[Hillary] I don't feel no ways tired.
[Trump] Let's see what happens.
[Hillary] That has been tried, that has failed.
[Trump] You gotta pay your bills!
[Hillary] I have a feeling that by the end of this evening
I'm gonna be blamed
[Hillary] for everything that's ever happened.
[Trump] Why not?
[Trump] I gotta use some Tic-Tacs just in case I start
kissing her.
[Trump] Thank God we have guns in case these guys
broke into the house
[Trump] and I'm a big second amendment person.
[Hillary] There is a constitutional right for people
to own guns,
[Hillary] but there is also constitutional right to life, liberty, and the-
*barking*
[Trump] She's become shrill!
[Trump] Extreme-vetting.
Hold it!
don't shoot!
A radio.
[Trump] Excuse me- how does that help us?
-are eating the flesh of the people they murder.
[Hillary] What kind of person believes that?
[Trump] The press is very dishonest, okay?
[Trump] And by the way I think their ratings are gonna
go down really sharply now.
Now you tell me those things can't get through
this lousy pile of wood.
[Trump] Im-penetrable.
[Hillary] I don't buy that.
[Trump] I buy it.
His wife and kid's downstairs.
[Hillary] I think the American dream is big enough for
everybody.
Judy?
Come on up here honey.
[Trump] Why not?
[Trump] Come in, come on in.
[Trump] We're stupid, we'll take care of you.
[Trump] Look, we have a lot of really bad dudes outside.
[Trump] It's far worse than anybody in this room understands, far worse.
[Trump] They're not supposed to be doing that.
[Trump] You have to go back.
[Trump] I'm a nice person, believe it or not, I mean
I have a heart.
[Trump] But you have to go back.
[Trump] Mortally wounded.
[Hillary] I respect anyone who when they're knocked
down gets back up.
[Trump] They're taunting us, okay?
[Trump] They're playing games with us.
[Trump] Bye bye.
[Hillary] Hot sauce!
[Trump] He was seriously hot.
[Hillary] Is it workin'?
[Trump] They're pretty much all gone, okay?
[Trump] pretty much.
[Trump] This is just a miserable way to spend a Sunday.
-I can't speak for the entire military at
this time-
[Trump] I'll tell you the generals aren't doing so
well right now.
[Trump] A little dark.
[Trump] Do you feel safe right now?
[Trump] I don't feel so safe.
[Trump] Get 'em out of here now! get 'em out!
[Trump] get 'em out!
[Trump] Try getting it out, try getting it out, go
ahead.
[Hillary] Cut it out!
[Trump] She doesn't have a chance.
[Trump] I believe Hillary's leaving.
[Trump] I like people that weren't captured, okay?
[Trump] I hate to tell you.
[Trump] Don't worry about that baby, I love babies.
[Trump] Actually I was only kidding you can get the
baby outta here.
[Trump] You know you can see there was blood coming
out of her eyes.
[Trump] Blood coming out of her- wherever.
[Trump] Childcare is such a big problem.
[Trump] What a stiff.
[Trump] More energy tonight, I like that.
[Trump] You're fired.
[Trump] Aye aye aye
[Trump] This is not easy stuff.
[Trump] Uh we'll do something let me go to sleep first.
*barking*
[Trump] Unbelievable!
[Trump] People are coming, and they have guns.
[Trump] And they shoot people.
Let's go check out the house.
There's something there, I heard a noise.
[Trump] These are very very good people and they're
protecting the second amendment.
Alright Vance, hit him in the head.
Right between the eyes.
[Trump] We're gonna take back our country and we're
gonna make America gre-
[Trump] I will sue.